la nuit dernière les réseaux sociaux
twitter et facebook ont annoncé qu'ils
avaient été utilisés par le pouvoir
chinois contre les manifestants à hong
kong
twitter a annoncé par un communiqué
qu'il avait suspendu 986 compte suspecté
d'avoir été financés par le pouvoir
chinois
facebook a de son côté suspendu cinq
pages 7 compte et trois groupes sur son
réseau social pour les mêmes raisons
alors même si ça peut paraître peu il
faut savoir que parmi les pages qui ont
été suspendus certaines d'entre elles a
été suivie par plus de 16 mille
utilisateurs sur le réseau social
donc c'est tout de même une opération
d'ampleur alors ses comptes ce sont des
faux comptes ce qu'on appelle des bottes
ce sont des contes automatique qui sont
financés par pékin pour diffuser de
l'information qui a été fabriqué ou
exagérées en l'occurrence contre les
manifestants sion à hong kong
alors ce n'est pas la seule stratégie
qui est employé par les pouvoir chinois
pour influencer les citoyens du monde
entier via les réseaux sociaux
la chine passe aussi par ce qu'on
appelle des publications sponsorisés en
clair sur facebook et sur twitter
le pouvoir chinois financent les réseaux
sociaux pour faire monter des messages
dans le fil d'actualité des utilisateurs
ça a notamment été le cas pour l' agence
de presse chinoise china xi noah news
qui est suspecté d'avoir payé twitter
pour faire remonter ces messages dans le
fil d'actualité sur facebook certaines
publications ont aussi été mises en
valeur notamment celles qui comparait
les manifestants d'hong kong à des
soldats de l'état islamique
alors ce qui est assez paradoxal c'est
que tous ces faux comptes sur twitter et
facebook ont dû contourner la censure du
pouvoir qu'ils soutiennent c'est à dire
la censure du pouvoir chinois
en fait en chine depuis 2009 les
principaux réseaux sociaux américains
donc comme twitter et facebook sont
interdits pour pouvoir y avoir accès il
faut passer par des logiciels qu'on
appelle des vpn qui permettent d'avoir
une adresse introuvable sur internet
alors ce n'est pas la première fois que
les réseaux sociaux sont utilisés par
des pouvoirs autoritaires
déjà l'année dernière le gouvernement
d'arabie saoudite avait créé des
centaines de faux comptes au moment de
la faire de l'assassinât du journaliste
jamal khashoggi à ce moment là en fait
le pouvoir saoudien était suspecté
d'avoir joué un rôle actif dans cet
assassinat et les faux comptes relayer
des informations pour le dédouaner dans
cette affaire